[Music]
hi you're gonna be late okay okay yeah
thanks mom a lamb is only as good as its
leaders somebody help me hey leave him
alone
a true king is brave and noble don't be
a hero on the King around here you have
more battles yet to fight you must
choose what you stand for
varus scores he was found something
written in the guard put it into google
translate it means sort of earth what if
you're the only person who could have
pulled that sort out what if it's
Excalibur
[Music]
ah finally follow me I am Merlin so -
push spin away an ingenious disguise do
you think in four days the dark sorcerer
Morgana will take over the world
this ridiculous
there's your sore back and good luck
with everything
you're a king Alexander the sword chose
you
while we helped you because you're the
strongest people I know you're my
Knights
and this is the round table quick better
lift up the flaps oh my god you're such
a nerd
this is this
like in every story we have read Luke
Skywalker Harry Potter something amazing
happens they find out they descended
from magical families mom don't freak
out okay
this is the best and
all hail the ones the future king
please don't it's embarrassing
what did you drive Mario Kart
I pee it's a prank YouTube thing a
social experiment maybe there were
hidden cameras
look there's something written on the
guard put it into Google Translate
Gladius artery
phileas cinta Kelly it's Latin it means
sword of Arthur son of Tintagel who's
tempted girl it's a place the island off
the coast of corn some people say it's
working off the was born thanks what if
you're the only person who could have
pulled that sort out what if it's what
if it's the sword in the stone to learn
the basics of sword craft you will need
a weapon each a simple duplication spell
for metallic objects should suffice
what are you doing boy I do magic tricks
for a hobby but I'm no good at
duplication illusions so you can a video
what you do and try and copy it I'll be
most impressed if you succeed
Wow now you have an army to fight demon
to slay the country to save so let us
begin doing
[Applause]
I'll fetch some food reward for once you
vanquished your phones
greetings voracious viral video viewers
I am Merlin Ambrosius Caledon ances I'm
here to teach you hand magic as seen in
the new motion picture the kid who would
be king today I'm going to teach you
mine to control this spell allows you to
compel anyone to do your bidding simply
look them directly in the eye no
blinking and to think your command while
performing the following gesture take me
east why not try and majid yourself I'll
be keeping an eye out for the best
younger sorceress greetings my name is
Merlin
Ambrosius Caledon ANSYS today I'm here
to teach you hand magic as seen in the
new motion picture the kid who would be
king
today's lesson is the art of portal
opening simply perform the following
gestures
[Music]
portals can only be open between pairs
of Paleolithic stones the majority of
which are in places with the terrible
weather why not try and manage it
yourself I'll be keeping an eye out for
the best young sorcerers a few days ago
something amazing happened
I found a sword in his stone kiddy would
be king is based on one of the most
famous myths in the world but it's
telling this legend in a completely new
way bringing it into the modern world
it's about a perfectly normal kid who
suddenly thrust into this massive
adventure
I was immediately intrigued by the whole
notion of transferring what is usually
looked on as a medieval piece into
modern-day
Google Translate means sort of Arthur
what if it's Excalibur its kids it's
magic it's colorful it's dragons it's a
fantastic adventure your King boy your
quest begins you have an army to fight
demon to slay a country to say that's
ridiculous there's your sore back and
good luck with everything
[Music]
what on earth are you children doing
saving Britain from eternal slavery it's
one of the greatest stories of all time
and told in truly remarkable and funny
way
what did you drive Mario Kart
greetings young scream gaseous I am
Merlin and Brocius Caledon ANSYS I'm
here to teach you hand magic as seen in
the new motion picture the kid who would
be king
today's lesson is the art of metal
duplication simply place a metallic
object on a surface before you and
perform these exact moves why not try
hand magic yourself I'll be keeping an
eye out for the best young sorceress hey
leave him alone it's a tough world out
there and it's getting tougher all the
time
and the world is not going to change
it's you that has to change
something amazing happened
you have to see what I found there's
something written in the guard put it
into Google Translate it means sort of
Arthur what if it's the sword in the
stone there are four days until the
solar eclipse when Morgana will enter
the world of the living
allows for supper that's ridiculous
on 12
I thought Nolan was a pushpin or what
you look for succeed an ingenious alias
in order to monitor incognito you will
need to assemble a team of Knights
bosses noise gathered a round table so
that they were all equal and look quick
Bettis lift up the flaps see oh my god
you're such a nerd this is destiny
the five of us won't stand a chance
Lauren
we need to raise an army how are you
Milly ating this is instead of lessons
today my worries
they must ever happened to me
why did you drive mariokart love don't
freak out okay Lady of the lake please
return Excalibur
[Music]
you